[Music]
well it's time once again for something
we call fan Corrections now this this of
course is a segment where viewers try to
find mistakes on our show okay so far
many many challengers know winners
that's right
we don't make mistake we do not make
don't make mistakes yeah tonight a fan
named Andrew says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
comment that I made about Thomas
Jefferson after a recent monologue joke
this is andrew i conan this is andrew
lichen and notice mistake on your April
14th show you made a joke about Donald
Trump running for president where you
implied that Thomas Jefferson wrote the
Constitution when's he gonna make the
announcement on his TV show yeah yeah
risking yeah as its laid out in the
Constitution Jefferson saw that this was
all necessary now we all know Thomas
Jefferson wrote the Declaration of
Independence but Jefferson was actually
in France when James Madison wrote the
Constitution bottom line is this Conan
you studied history at Harvard you
should not have made that mistake
good god I love his movie his eyes don't
even look at me well listen Andrew you
may have access to ominous big-city
backdrops okay I'll give that to him I
don't know what that's all about what's
look like a cable access talk show yeah
in your man cave but you apparently you
don't have access to the truth about US
history yes Jefferson was in Paris but
that doesn't mean he didn't help right
the Constitution
check out this very rare footage from
the Library of Congress
yes Madison what is it Oh TJ thank God
you gotta help me out so far all I got
is hey everybody
oh no I am we the people I like that of
the United States in order to form a
more perfect union well this is gold tea
Jeff keep it flowing establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility your sweet
tongue Virginia you're saving my ass you
to give me Co credit right you're
breaking up
[Applause]
here I don't want to have any viewers
right in that they didn't have
cellphones back then or that they didn't
have bicycles or that that's what does I
can't our wasn't built yet okay when you
pedal a bicycle it actually moves I
don't want to hear any of that crap I'm
right once again what you got more
what's with Madison's eyebrow shut up oh
you're not helping
[Laughter]
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at Team koco.com / haha I
found an error and we'll sort it out in
a very fair way here on the air will
research the facts in the Beaufort time
yeah keep it in it Chucky how do the
maestro